okay so Warner Brothers flew out myself
and a whole bunch of comic book influent
really like YouTube influence she's like
youtubers um people on the DC Universe
app who are like moderators like all
these people who were involved in like
the DC Universe app and who are
influencers on social media and the
comic book industry and and you know who
the gaming industry to a degree wonder
brothers flew us all out to LA and we
got to spend the weekend checking out
this whole DC Universe event that they
have going on which is really showcasing
like word sat now which like the DC
Universe like it's well they're also
showcasing things they have later on um
but they're there there's something that
I can't that I cannot talk about you
kind of have to sign up for the DC
Universe app to find out but I promise
they're worth it the DC Universe app is
beast um it's like it's like this
one-stop-shop for DC right so like you
have Marvel unlimited but it's just like
comic books and even then like the
organization is pretty tough but with DC
Universe like it's organized as
categorized like you've got you've got
like everything related to DC so you got
TV shows you have like like you know
comics you've got you've got you've
actually got color books you can look at
the character and then find all the
comics associated with that character so
it makes reading order super simple um
but there's also a promo code down in
the in the description of this video
now the promo code only works until
April 1st so make sure you guys like
sign up for it as soon as you can
but the promo code will get you 20% off
the annual pass right so it's not
monthly it's not the monthly pass it's
just $20 for the annual or 20% off for
the annual pass but it's worth it
so you guys should you guys should
definitely go you guys should definitely
get it because I mean it's I mean I've
got it it's pretty legit okay so picking
up with yours in crisis part 6 like a
lot of this a lot of the story that
we've seen so far it's kind of split
into sections so we're gonna kind of
take each one of these because what it
does is actually sort of bounces back
and forth between a guy named narc and
then Holly Quinn and then Wally West so
we're gonna kind of take these in
segments but with Harley Quinn like like
hers is really the most straightforward
because what's ironic about this is that
was sanctuary poison ivy had shown up
here presumably for the sake of like
getting help but for the most part
poison ivy just kind of like I'm fine
the way I am this was really more for
Harley Quinn so it's really more that
like she snuck freely Quinn in there
which is kind of a bad guy doing what a
bad guy does I guess but and they're
just behind this really seems to be more
towards kind of leaning towards the idea
that they're really kind of appeared to
be some criminals out there who are just
incorrigible and that the indication
seems to be that Holly Quinn was
perceived as being one of those
criminals that there was really no way
helper there was no way to make her
better but the cool thing about this is
that honking kinda hits on the idea that
she's not that far gone what she needed
was the right kind of treatment and the
way this seems to kind of come about is
when poison ivy starts helping Harley
Quinn by basically creating like these
manifestations of the Joker and what
they do is go through and essentially
like torment the Joker and kill him
destroy him that kind of different thing
because that's what the Joker did to
Harley Quinn and that's one of the
things to bear in mind here is that a
lot of those themes that weren't
necessarily hit on you know that were
really hit on the nose
in Batman the Animated Series certainly
were in the comics that the Joker was
exceedingly abusive but Harley Quinn
kept coming back due to some more
perspective of what love is supposed to
be now how how called Harley Quinn got
to that point is really kind of
reflective of whatever her origin story
is right I mean she's got one origin
story and Batman the Animated Series
she's got another origin story and the
actual DC Comics and then she's got
another origin story when she was
rebooted in the new 52 but throughout
all of those the common themes are
basically that Harley Quinn in some form
or fashion was kind of brought up with
it with a victims mentality with kind of
like an abusive mentality so it's kind
of strange the way it all plays out but
again it sort of makes sense with her
character in terms of how she's
progressed so far so like literally
poison ivy is using her her vines so I
killed the Joker like the Joker is like
killing himself basically like cutting
his own throat it's basically using
these things as a means to kind of help
Harley get past the kind of pain that
she's experienced and stop seeing the
Joker is someone that could legitimately
torment her and sue the Joker is
somebody who's just easily killed
because a lot of ways the Joker is the
Joker is really like an easily killable
guy the story of Harley Quinn kind of
ends when the alarm bells go off
basically saying like you know there's
an emergency you guys all need to make
their way to the exit because Harley's
not supposed to be there poison ivy
tells her stay here I'm gonna go see
what's going on and then of course as we
know poison ivy dies and so what we end
up doing at this point is we switch over
to two Wally West's now for Wally West
is kind of interesting here because the
big torment of Wally isn't necessarily
like any sort of scenario he's been put
through as a hero with regards to like a
villain he faced it took like an
emotional toll or anything like that
it's being cut off from the world like
that's the torment of Wally West that
when everything happened with flashpoint
and the characters were effectively
rebooted Wally West was stuck in the
Speed Force
so when Barry Allen came out when the
whole reboot finished Barry Allen had
like his whole life and he was so sure
of the life you lived being the right
one with like Donna Troy and Dick
Grayson and all those characters living
their lives they've effectively live
their lives the way they're supposed to
Wally West is suddenly being thrown in
here and because of the fact that like
this this huge event of flashpoint
happen and nobody remembers what
happened before the events of Flashpoint
Wally's mindset being he's one of the
few who does remember is like things
aren't the way they're supposed to be he
does he's not married to his wife he's
not married to Linda Park he can't find
giant irises kids so in his mind like
the world's literally in shambles and
for a brief moment when Barry Allen
basically realized who he was and Barry
Allen brought him back it was kinda like
hate like everything's gonna go back to
the way it was supposed to only for us
to find out that it's not that was kind
of interesting that the wakê way Tom
King does this because in reality Tom
King doesn't really do anything to
change the nature of Wally West what he
does is he uses a story to frame the
perspective of Wally West in a slightly
different way that it really is just
kind of a crushing situation that
there's no going back that that's kind
of the fear and really the basis behind
Wally West's life right now he can't go
back to the way things used to be and
that's kind of the cool thing about the
the heroes and crisis story and the
nature of Wally is because when Superman
embraces him and says hey man like your
back and when Nightwing embraces him and
Donna Troy embraces him and and Roy
Harper embraces and they keep saying
like your back man you're the embodiment
of Hope but the question that Wally has
is how could I be the embodiment of Hope
if I'm hopeless and that's kind of
that's kind of the cool scenario here is
things change the world moves forward
you've got to change with the times
it was kind of a cool little thing
because when of course all that begins
to go down when all that begins to
happen basically like Wally despite
despite the fact he's he's basically
surrounded by the Titans despite the
fact that Superman knows who he is
because Superman knows how things work
before the events of Flashpoint be it
despite the fact that he's surrounded by
like Barry Allen iris West these people
that essentially know who he is it
doesn't change the fact that Wally West
in his entirety feels completely alone
he feels completely alone and cut off
because from his perspective he's in a
world that he doesn't belong in and so
that's what makes it kind of crazy so
again it's really interesting because
again like the alarm bells go off and
they're all kind of comes to a head now
again well we'll get to that point here
in a second in terms of what comes next
but at this point we jump back to a
character named narc now narc was a
character who originally appeared back
in 1971 by Steve Skeets I think it was
the guy who created him but essentially
he's like an old-school pre-crisis
character but essentially like this
version of his character is kind of
reminiscing on how things were back in
the in the early days of his life and in
the early days of narcs life he was just
like a Neanderthal right like he was a
caveman essentially and what had
happened was that a meteorite had struck
the earth and then a fraction of that
meteorite some of the crystal compose
inside bonded itself to him and
basically
like jump-started his in his intellect
made him super smart when that happened
of course eventually he was frozen in
ice and then basically he was stuck
there for like hundreds and thousands of
years until he was eventually discovered
by like the Teen Titans being dispelled
by the Teen Titans he was essentially
let loose and then like kind of join the
team for a little while and then his
fate was never really specified now in
the new 52 we ended up learning like
there was like a new version of him but
again none of that really ties into like
how his character quote-unquote died
according to Lilith in the in the pre
flashpoint landscape but again at this
moment right now because of the fact
that he's so intelligent he reminisces
on characters like Hobbs and Andrew so
now Hobbs is uh is basically talking
about Thomas Hobbs and Thomas Hobbs was
his philosopher that had this really
really dark perspective right like he
considered the nature of humanity to be
a perpetual of permanent war of all
against all you had something called a
state of nature
there was no ordered government it was
just kind of humans really more of like
what passes for nomadic tribes just kind
of making their way but it's essentially
a state of nature no order government of
any kind
Thomas Hobbes believed that because
resources are finite that resources
basically have to be preserved but the
only way to really preserve those
resources is to create what was called
the Leviathan which is essentially like
an order government created by whatever
society exists at the time and so again
like there are a lot of other themes
that go into it in terms of like abuses
of power
if a king abuses his powers it's just
the way it goes there's really not a
whole lot you can do about that I mean
you could try to overthrow the king but
a new one will take his place and then
he may be just abusive as well it's the
price you pay to maintain some kind of
like order and structure in society that
you can't have it all but again Thomas
Hobbes was very dark and very very bleak
but at the same time when dark is kind
of talking about his life he says there
was a lot of freedom back then like in
the early days of his life there was a
lot of freedom that a man really just
kind of lived by the sweat of his brow
that's all it was you know that he
basically he fought with nature in order
to kind of maintain his role among
nature itself you know and that's when
he kind of begins to go into
jean-jacques Rousseau and jean-jacques
Rousseau is a philosopher who compared
the modern day to the the the state of
nature and basically said state of
nature was better because people had
actual freedom though there really is no
freedom right now there's freedom
insofar as your ability to make
decisions but your ability to make
decisions is predicated based on like
societal structures right so like I'm
going to tweet but I have to make sure I
don't tweet the wrong thing otherwise I
could lose my job ten years later I mean
that is that kind of it's not really
freedom per se you can't say anything
you want to you can't do anything you
want to your limit
by like the rules of society by the
scope of the society that you live in
and that's really kind of what it was
what rock hits at is he had absolute
freedom back then that the only real
rules of society the only real rules of
the world he lived in was survival of
the fittest that he needs to eat
but another Neanderthal needs to eat and
so where he tracks down the kill another
the end of thought will run upon him and
try to take it and basically whoever's
the strongest kills the other and then
gets to feast on the on the on the
animal they killed that was the rule of
nature it was the law of the land those
who were strong enough to survive are
the only ones who deserve to survive so
again it was it's a little bit darker
but again like there's a lot of a lot of
themes of freedom that go in there and
it's kind of interesting when you look
at it that way because mark kind of has
a point there like back in his early
days it really was just freedom he was
free to do whatever he wanted to to live
his life however he wanted to there were
no bounds there there were no limits
there the only limits imposed on him
were the physical limits of his body at
that point in time the limits of where
he could travel in terms of what's too
cold what's too hot and the limits in
terms of what his mind could comprehend
and that was it everything else he could
do whatever he wanted to and imagine
that kind of freedom imagine the freedom
to go where you want when you want how
you want to say anything you want to
like imagine that kind of freedom and
then compare that to the modern day and
look how free you really not that was
kind of the argument of jean-jacques
Rousseau you're not really as free as
you believe you're as free as you've
been told and so it's it's really kind
of a cool comparison between these these
two different philosophies but again
like you know the alarm bells go off
mark ends up making his way off and
basically says hey look maybe I'm kind
of overthinking it all but at the same
time like that's what everything kind of
begins to unfold again when like all
these different superheroes end up
getting killed on the grounds of
sanctuary and so that's what we
basically end up finding out Booster
Gold was the one who killed Wally West
and presumably Booster Gold was the one
who killed everybody else that seems to
be the case here as was it's kind of
interesting because what is what is sort
of hits at is that when Harley Quinn had
shown up there with a blood splattered
mallet that mallet was actually her like
smashing the Joker Lisa seems to be that
she was killing the various duplicates
of the Joker that were being made in
sanctuary as a way to basically heal her
wounds she wasn't actually going through
and killing superheroes the actual
killer here seems to be Booster Gold so
again is pretty interesting and it and
it's really well I really like the
direction that it's taking in terms of
how the story is unfolding but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained and make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later